we don't get a super bowl mvp on the
program very often but we get one today
thanks to the new old spice foamer it's
a foaming body wash that lathers in a
flash von miller is partnering with old
spice for the foam zone obstacle course
game show on old spice's youtube twitch
and facebook live channel
tuesday 5 p.m to 11 p.m eastern what in
the heck is the foam zone obstacle
course game show vaughn
it's a um
football theme i've stick a course that
is covered in the old spice
foamer and um
fans they can tune in and actually
influence the obstacle course so it's uh
it's pretty cool and like you said they
can um
they can see it on all the old spice
media
channels from 5pm to 11pm
are you actually going to be a
contestant in this obstacle course
no no i'm not going to be in
the contestant but they do have a
von miller statue that guys would be
climbing up and it'll be covered in the
phone too so it's pretty cool you can
catch that up you can catch that on all
the old spy social media channels like i
said before from 5 pm to 11 pm eastern
you know one thing i've been meaning to
ask you about do you still do the
chicken farming
oh yes sir 100 that's that's me all over
how big is it now
um we got about like uh 35 acres uh it's
35 acres uh yeah yeah it's it's just on
the way it's going
do you ever chase the chickens like
rocky and rocky too
no no i don't chase them they they are
pretty quick though the thing is though
whenever you are chasing chickens no you
you don't really chase them just like
take your time like walk walk up on them
be calm and that uh that usually works
for me
so you sneak up on the chicken and then
you make your move
not really not really just sneak up on
them just just be patient and just be
calm and
usually if you're calm the chickens will
come and it it makes it easy to pick him
up
what was your key
to uh uh getting russell wilson on the
ground as many times you did because
that's got to be even harder than
chasing a chicken trying to tackle that
guy
yeah it's about the same technique just
just be calm you know just uh don't rush
it just let them run and run to you just
keep the same wrench lanes and you'll be
all right
how much did you study the way that he
likes to spin away from the pocket get
outside of the pocket how much of that
is a factor when you're facing a russell
wilson the lanes that you take whether
you go inside whether you go outside the
things you do to try to get to a guy
like that
um you know you really don't put too
much into it because whenever you play
them it's gonna be totally different
it's gonna be totally different than
once you've watched the film you just
want to get to them and you just want to
work with uh the guys that you have
around
the guys that you have around you to
just get him on the ground he's a great
quarterback and if you leave any lane
he's gonna take it
what do you send donald penn for what
you did to him on sunday when you threw
him down
on the ground did he get does he get
some old spice products does he get some
chicken does he get uh you know fruit
basket uh thank you note or condolences
what does he get
i mean
defense is a great he's a great guy i
feel like
you know he's my he's my teammate i've
been knowing him so long and we've never
even been on the same teams so
dpn though it was just it was just game
day you know i got it i got to get mine
too
did i mean it looked like he got crossed
up a little bit and it was easier to
just knock him down on the ground
i don't know i was just i was just
rushing just trying to get from point a
to point b as fast as possible i i
really don't like to put too much
emphasis on offense alignment or moves
or anything like that i'm just to keep
it simple i just try to get from point a
to point b as fast as possible
but
when do you know in a given play what
you're going to do whether you're going
to try to go inside outside spin bull
rush whatever when do you come to that
conclusion as to how you're going to get
to the quarterback
probably uh probably two steps into the
rush
you know i really don't have like any
premeditated moves
um i just try to get a great jump on the
ball and like uh
probably off the second step i know if
i'm going to speed the power long arm
boo spin
probably
i know it alpha where the offensive
alignment is so it's just uh just try to
get a great jump on every play
what quarterback do you like chasing the
most
i mean you don't really like chasing
another one you know you want to get
them on the ground if you're tasting
them you know that's not that's not good
for us
you just want to get to them and
whenever you get to them you just want
them to fall like that's the that was
the quarterbacks that the def that
passport she's like going after the
quarterbacks right when you touch them
that they fought not the russell
wilson's
or the derry cars or the carson wentz
you want the quarterbacks that
that's just gonna this is gonna fall
right then when you get to them
where does the next guy you face fit
into that category joe flacco tall guy
not real mobile is he a guy who goes
down when you hit him
uh you know yeah kind of disorder i mean
i mean kind of sort of joe fleck he's
one of the lead quarterbacks in the
league and
you know he's not going to give up sacks
that's a given and he's pretty good with
the ball
and um yeah he has they have a great
offensive line over there so it's going
to be another tough task for us this
week
what do we make of this new protection
of quarterbacks and you know it's almost
like you can't hit them high you can't
hit them low and if you hit them in the
middle you better be careful because if
you land on you're going to get flagged
for that too how are you supposed to get
a quarterback on the ground when you
have to be so careful about the strike
zone and also how hard you strike them
um yeah just i just go for the ball you
know i just go for the ball you know
that's um
that's my whole mindset i feel like sac
fumble is the biggest play
in uh in football and that's what i'm
trying to do i'm trying to get the ball
back for my offense each and every time
so if if i'm open and i got a clean shot
on the quarterback i'm going for the
ball and let me tell you i got some of
the worst roughing the passer calls out
so i totally understand you know how
clay is feeling today but
from my point of view i just go for the
ball every time
you know vaughn it's funny we're talking
so much about roughing the passer after
two weeks of the nfl season a month ago
everyone thought we'd be talking about
this new lowering the helmet rule that's
essentially gone away why do you think
that hasn't been a bigger factor through
the first two weekends
uh i think it's uh we just uh did a
great job as uh
as opposed to um
adjusting to the new rule you know it's
always to be rude changes the game is
always going to change and all the great
ones they always have this ability to
adapt to the game and i think
as a whole you know
defenses
have started to adapt to it
who do you think is the best pass rusher
right now in the nfl
um besides myself or uh yeah
obviously besides you yeah
von miller number one who's number two
right
i can't vote for myself so i mean all
right it's a lot of guys it's a lot of
guys it just depends
on what a team or or or that day you
know sex coming bunches you know one guy
could have you know three sex this day
and and not have another sex for the
next three weeks
so it just depends i think um some of
the greats that
have done it consistently over the last
couple of years of of course you know
khalil um chandler jones um
aaron donald can't forget you know jj
watt and the guys over in houston with
clowney and all of those guys so it just
depends it just depends on the week to
be to lead in the league you just got to
stay hot every every week you got to
stay hot every week and i've never led
um that's a football league in sax and
you know hopefully this will be the year
when you see what happened with khalil
mack and the raiders what lessons do you
take away from that that may apply to
yourself either in the past or in the
future
um yeah i you know like guys like khalil
and jj and
you know aaron donald you would think
that guys like that are untradable you
would like to you know keep guys like
that in your organization for as long as
possible but you know obviously it
doesn't you know work like that you just
gotta
be able to take advantage of the
opportunity when it presents itself and
you know so clearly he went to a great
team was able to one one player change
the whole organization and that's what
you uh that's what you wish for just uh
just keep playing and let your play
speak for you
were you happy to see khalil mack leave
the afc west
yeah i was i was you know good good play
by the raiders
you know that definitely it definitely
helps the broncos out but you know at
the end of the day you know i like the
i like the the battles that we had you
know going against him you know he'd get
a sack i get a shack you know that was
dope it's always like that in the afc
west you know from the raiders to you
know the chargers and the chiefs chiefs
they have
two great passengers over there as well
with justin houston and d ford and
everybody knows about the charges with
with joey bosin and melvin ingram so it
still look it's still a afc west but
it's just missing one guys
that's just how the league is
heyvon you said earlier you don't focus
on offensive linemen but is there one
guy out there that's kind of like the
joker to your batman where you just
don't want to see this guy you you dread
having to try to get past him
i mean yeah that's that's uh
i mean really any offensive alignment
can be that for me if you add a chipper
and if you had a tight end trip you feel
adding a slide and you're adding a
running back you know chipping it it's
tough you know
it's tough when you have you know all
that attention and lucky for you know me
and my team we have a lot of great pass
rushers
um shaq shane and bradley chubb that are
gonna help out this year so you know you
just gotta you know if if it's a joker
on the other side of my batman you gotta
rely on robin to come help you so
it's a team
sport a team
it's a team sport and we got a lot of
we've got a lot of pass rushers over
here
how's bradley chubb doing so far
bradley's doing great man it's uh it's
definitely relieving when you get young
guys in like bradley chubb and according
to sudden and philip lindsey you know
guys like that they could just come in
and really change the organization in
you know a matter of weeks and you know
we got we got a great supporting cast
with those young guys and
we we've been great through two weeks
and we just got to keep pushing
how much different is it this year with
case keenum at quarterback
oh it's different you know uh
you know paxton and um
and trevor they did a great job for the
organization they did a great job for us
but you know case is just a special
player he's just special all the way
around and when you have a guy like that
it definitely it definitely changes
everything on the offense and when you
got offense like that it makes the
defense that more effective
okay one more before i let you run i
know you take the games one at a time
you don't play the chiefs this weekend
but they're coming and you see what
patrick mahomes is doing in that offense
how tempting is it to start thinking
about what you're going to try to do to
counter what he's done so far
i mean patrick mahomes has just been hot
you know 10 touchdowns through two weeks
is just incredible um you know the
chiefs they had a great team last year
they got great players other than
patrick mahomes from travis kelsey to
to um
you can't you you you can't forget um
you know all the guys they have they
have one of the best offensive lines in
football as well tyreek hill is playing
lights out kareem hunt you know they
just stacked all across the board you
just gotta
you know hope that uh you know they kind
of cool down a little bit whenever we
play them and whenever we play we just
gotta go out there and play
well hey vaughn you're off to a great
start 2-0 we thank you as always for
including us in these visits and we will
check out the foam zone obstacle course
course game show old spices youtube
twitch and facebook live channels
tuesday 5 p.m to 11 p.m eastern and we
look forward to talking to you soon
thanks vaughn
all righty thanks and giggling
appreciate you guys
you